ها هو المدون العسكري الروسي الشهير
فلادين تاتارسكي قبل دقائق من مقتله داخل
هذا المقهى الذي استاجرته مجموعه سايبر
فروندي الملقبه بجنود الاعلام في روسيا
بعد تلاقيه هذا التمثال على شكل جندي
كهديه هزا انفجار عنيف ارجاء مقاهر
من وسط مدينه
التاريخيه كما تظهره هذه الصور
بعدما قدمت له احدى المعجبات تمثالا صغيرا
بثلاث او خمس دقائق وقع الانفجار اخذت
الميكروفون وقالت انها تحترمه وتعرفه وان
الهديه من مجموعه تنتمي اليها لكن ما هي
هذه المجموعه لا اعلم فور مقتله اغلقت
الطرقات المؤديه الى المقهى وتوقت الشرطه
المكان وقبل تحديد هويه المتورطين سرعت
وزاره الخارجيه الى توجيه اصابع الاتهام
الى كيافه
يتعرض الصحفيون الروس باستمرار للتهديد
بالانتقام من سلطات كييف ومن يدعمونها
وبشكل متزايد تتارسكي كان يعتبر شخصا خطرا
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا كان مكسيم من الملقب
بفلادين
عن الهجوم الروسي منذ اكثر من عام كثفت
دعمه للجنود الروس في منطقه دومباس
الاوكرانيه مسقط راسه عبر تقديم النصائح
العسكريه لهم
كما كان يطل من داخل قصر الكرملين على
اكثر من نصف مليون شخص من متابعيه ببث
مباشر ليؤكد دعمه للعمليات العسكريه في
الداخل الاوكراني